bonjour bienvenue sur 974 TV qui un jour
n'a pas utilisé une tisane à la
citronnelle pour soigner une mauvaise
grippe nous allons aujourd'hui parler de
zerbage pays et sur ce plateau je reçois
de fin connaisseurs de la question on
commence avec Claude marudon qui est à
ma droite pharmacien de son état mais
surtout président de la plamédom et
unassionné de plantes pays alors à côté
de Monsieur Marodon Fabiane de Verdière
qui travaille au service environnement
de direction deenvironnement conseil
général à ma gauche un tisaneur ou
plutôt un tisanier donc il s'agit de
monsieur Jean-Jacques silou silon silon
pardon et Fabio laposé qui nous vient de
salasie qui est éducatrice spécialisée
donc Fabien de verd pourquoi le Conseil
général a mis en place cette formation
alors déjà j'aimerais rapidement
faire l'historique de ce projet il y a 3
ans la plaméom nous a consulté pour
pouvoir donc financer une publication
euh qui est donc présent sur euh
présente sur la table le livréabas pays
et donc à la lecture de ce livrés à bas
pays on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
donc euh deux approches qui pouvaient
être intéressantes d'abord l'approche
des plantes endémiques préservation de
des plantes endémiques protection de la
biodiversité euh parce que l'ensemble
des plantes présentes dans ce livret
était donc des plantes d'origine
endémique pour certaines et il y avait
aussi ce côté je dis rétransmission du
savoir-faire des traditions on a été euh
on a été donc confronté à certains
problème de des agents qui étaient sur
le terrain qui il sont confrontés à un
public qui a une méconnaissance totale
de ce de cette de ce savoir et ce savoir
erroné peut entraîner de graves dangers
entre autes malheureusement le décès
donc voyant donc un projet avec un
double volet il nous a paru intéressant
de le financer et nous avons donc défini
ensemble avec la plamédom la mise en
place donc cette formation destinée aux
agents des arrondissements le test a été
lancé en 2010 au près de
l'arrondissement Nord ce test donc a été
un succès réel puis nous avons étendu ce
projet à l'ensemble des arrondissements
plus précisément non pas pour l'ensemble
des agents mais pour les agents qui sont
sur le terrain et qui rencontrent un
public dit socialement fragile
c'est-à-dire les gudes PMI et autres
services très bien alors monsieur
marudon vous êtes pharmacien donc
passionné des des des herbag pay est-ce
qu'il était important comme ça de
laisser une trace un écrit des notes
explicatives pour que les gens utilisent
c'est même essentiel c'est-à-dire que
l'association œuvre La plamédom œuvre
dans la reconnaissance des des plantes
mais aussi la valorisation de tout ce
savoir traditionnel qui est souvent est
oral et que justement en transcrivant en
faisant des concours d'herbiers de
plantes médicinales avec des enquêtes et
ben on contribue on participe à écrire
toute cette tradition et à péréniser en
fait ce savoir donc c'est même la base
même de l'association puisqueensuite
avec toutes ces bases de données nous
allons valoriser les plantes en fonction
de leur usage de leur toxicité même on
va faire appel à des scientifiques à des
universitaires qui vont étudier la
composition des plantes leurs effets
éventuellement même s'il y a une
toxicité avoir ensuite des
recommandations pour que éviter que les
gens fassent des erreurs alors est-ce
que ça voulait dire que les tisanur
faisaent un peu n'importe quoi alors pas
du tout vous vous rejoignez sur alors
l'tilisation de ces plantes on va dire
que nos ancêtres sont arrivés à la
Réunion ils utilisent des plantes
endémiques et c'est l'occasion justement
de faire vérifier par les
scientifiques la validité de de leur
vertu donc c'est l'opportunité de de de
les mettre en avant et donc il y a des
plantes qui sont toxiques qui sont
utilisées quand même dans le dans la
tradition mais tout ça c'est le douxâge
déjà qui agit et aussi sur la durée
parce que que sur des très de très
courte durée l'élimination de ces de ces
toxines c'est par exemple comme la
sensitive he pour ne parler plus loin la
sensitive elle est citée dans ce livre
c'est bon pour faire pour le sommeil
pour les insomnies mais elle est toxique
elle a aussi justement sa toxicité à
forte dose qui peut être mortelle il y a
aussi des des des mati la dents aussi
qui fait tomber les cheveux donc appr
prendre avec précaution et avec
délicatesse grâce à la formation on a
appris que ben il y a des par exemple
comme Camara par exemple que l' utiliser
pour la fièvre et ben il faut doser il
faut savoir doser alors que les gens ils
prendent ça à tout va AAP Maron mais tu
savais pas qu' était quand même vous
pouvez pas boire ça alors que les gens
ils boient et alors qu'il faut prendre
le bain avec et donc justement l'idée
était venue donc avec Madame duriè dans
la pas méom donc de pouvoir en fait
mettre en place donc des sessions en
fait des pas des sessions par là il en N
rend plus les plus professionnels mais
avec ces parentsl et ces grandsparents
là que y a que les dans le groupe de
parents sur maraville place donc mettre
en place une journée de sensibilisation
déjà pour pouvoir en fait donc rétablir
un peu les choses donc pour pouvoir
mettre en fait en adéquation en fait
tout ce que nous connais et puis que les
gens fent plus n'importe quoi aussi he
donc ce que madame de disait il peut
provoqu la mort il souvent il prend
médicament il prend tisane et il peut
aussi AR des choses terribles donc
pouvoir en fait avec àd avec Madame
duriz en particulier donc mettre en
place une jourée sensibilisation ensuite
n n a aussi de l'ambition donc avec
Madame duriè de pouvoir en fait
continuer donc aller visiter donc un
jardin donc avec un tisanier donc en ces
gens-là sur le terrain nous nous nous
parle de biodiversité nous parle de
l'économie donc nous est vraiment
là-dedans donc sur sur le terrain donc
vraiment que les gens il il recultivent
quelque part il recultiv parce que même
si nous salasie on a une perte aussi he
des traditions il gardent mais bon on a
quand même avec les jeunes est en train
de perdre donc du coup nous disnous que
ben il serait peut-être pas mal de
réhabiliter tout ça donc au niveau au
niveau conseil général on a la
possibilité dans les moyens de faire ça
donc pouvoir en fait euh donc que les
gens ils visitent donc un petit jardin
un jardin et voir comment on peut faire
ça et ensuite donc on a aussi donc cette
ambition de pouvoir organiser un moment
ou un autre une grande journée donc de
de l'artisane donc ça c'est vraiment
dans les perspectives hein c'est
vraiment assez loin très bien ben merci
à tous nos invités merci ça a été très
enrichissant et à bientôt sur notk
T